So how do we parallelize scan?
Let's first start with
the prefix sum problem.
Once we understand that we'll have
a pattern for parallelizing any scan.
By analogy to reducing
an array to a single value,
if we assume associativity,
then we can rearrange partial sums.
So somehow we want to use this idea for
parallelizing scan as well.
So assume associativity and
consider a scan of this input array.
You could try by doing the same
thing you did in a reduction, for
example let's take every pair of
elements and let's combine them.
The result will be a new set
of partial consecutive sums.
For example,
this node is the sum from 1 to 2 and
this node is the sum from 3 to 4.
In fact let me label each intermediate
sum with a notation A colon B.
The important point is that these
are consecutive partial sums.
So with this notation, this is what
the final output should look like so
let's go back to the partial sums.
Suppose you could magically and
recursively do an add
scan on the partial sums.
That is,
I take these partial sum values and
I somehow magically
apply a scan to them.
What would I get?
In this case I would get 1:2
as the first scan element.
Then for the second scan element
I would get 1:2 plus 3:4.
In other words, 1:4.
And for the third element,
I get 1:2 plus 3:4 plus 5:6.
In other words, 1:6.
And then finally, 1:8.
Notice what that gives you,
all of the even results.
So, voila.
We've done half the work.
Now what about the odd results?
How do we get those?
Well, that should be easy.
If I went 1:3,
I just take 1:2 and add 3.
You can do the same thing for
1:5 and 1:7.
Voila.
You're done.
Stop for a second and
make sure that that makes sense.
Now I claim here's some pseudo code
that implements this scheme we just
described.
Let's do a quick analysis to
make sure we got it right.
Now here I sub O and I sub E store
the odd and even indices respectively,
that is, 1, 3, 5, 7 and so
on and 2, 4, 6, 8 and so on.
Now this particular algorithm
is in place adding the odd and
even elements over here
corresponds to this line.
By in place, I mean we take this result
and we overwrite the even elements.
This magic recursive step appears here.
And this final combine
step appears here.
Now, note that I've used this python
slicing notation to mean starting at
element 2 and
going to the end of the array.
If you can convince yourself that n
equals 1 produces the correct result,
then you can use induction to prove
that the overall algorithm is correct.